Do you ever crave something
and it turns out to be so much better
than you could have ever imagined?
That's what happened to me today when I was craving lasagna soup.
It's getting a little chilly outside,
so that means it's soup season.
I started by making my mozzarella
by combining some citric acid and rennet,
heating it up, cutting it into cubes,
letting the way separate, and then straining it.
Return my curds back to hot water,
let them melt, stretch them out,
warm my ball of mozzarella,
and set that aside while I got started on my pasta dough.
I combined flour, eggs,
olive oil, and a pinch of salt.
Started needing my dough, but got tired,
so lucky took over.
I let that rest for about an hour while I got started on my sauce.
I chopped up some celery, moved on to some onion,
and lastly some carrot. I seared off some ground beef and ground pork,
then added my celery, onion,
and carrot.
Let that saute for a few minutes before adding in my tomato paste.
I let that go, added in some crushed tomatoes,
some stock, some Italian spices.
While that was simmering and getting to know each other,
I rolled out my pasta,
cut it into a regular shapes before I transfer that over to the sauce,
and let it cook in the sauce.
After about four minutes, started slicing up my mozzarella,
putting that in the sauce as well
so it Could melt. Once the mozzarella had melted,
it was time to plate.
I topped this with some Parmesan cheese and some spring onions.
This hit the spot and was absolutely stunning.
And I can't wait for colder weather.